I'm going to do something really
different I'm not going to ask you about
Secretary Clinton and her decision to
run for office if you feel like sharing
that with us I'm sure we'd all be happy
to hear that I don't know but I'm for
whatever she wants to do
I know this is an immensely rewarding
thing that's the one thing I wanted to
say to all of you that the fundamental
fact of power in a highly integrated
interdependent world with is that it is
more dispersed the good news is you have
more of it and you can come here and
form alliances and drastically increase
your impact so but the bad news is
people are trying to wreck things have
more influence too and the the
traditional nation-state all over the
world is under stress which is driving
some people to support more
authoritarian governments and we don't
want that in America so it's not like
you can't have a meaningful life outside
of politics but it's not like politics
is not still really important it's just
for the rest of the life of everybody in
this room you're going to live in a
period where power is more dispersed and
the competition exercise it in positive
and negative weight will probably go to
people who are most effective in
recognizing the new realities and
organizing and deploying according to it
and so that's so whatever she decides to
do she's gonna do good and and what does
that mean about you in other words you
have spent more than a decade out of
office devoting your life creating this
extraordinary foundation to the public
good what would a return to the white
house for your family mean for the
foundation and for CGI and for the work
that you're so meaningfully engaged in
today well I hope that it we would be
able to continue to do what we do but
that we would set up certain rules and
have be totally transparent so that no
one would think
that someone was helping the clinton
foundation because they wanted to edge
with the federal government when hillary
was secretary of state for example i
cleared every speech I gave particularly
those I gave as I do every year a lot of
to raise money for the foundation I
cleared in advance what the policy would
be on taking any funds from non-american
sources they'd the White House developed
a policy we publish what the policy was
I reported every penny we got if we made
a mistake someone can see it and say I
think this was wrong but I don't think
we should shut down the Clinton Global
Initiative or a program that now gets
aids medicine and more than six million
people in the world more than half
people in the world get their aids
medicine all contracts we negotiated 75%
of all the kids I think we shouldn't
have to shut it down and you know I need
if she were to run and become president
the last thing she needs is for me to be
underfoot I would do she's able as
public servant I've ever known she
wouldn't I would help whatever I was
asked to do I would be I believe just
like I do for President Obama just like
I did for president bush I mean I think
that's you've been a former president
you need to show up when you're summing
but um
but but I hope that we can keep this
because this too is a part of advancing
the public good and the 21st century